can you see up this scenario assume that
your elected president of the United
States are sitting in the Oval Office
can you see yourself signing a bill or a
directive abolishing the Federal Reserve
well a lot would have to happen you know
if if I went there and I was a
libertarian president and the Congress
remained the same and the spending was
continuing and the people still wanted
all this big government no I can't I
can't sign a bill because it would have
been passed in the first four years of a
libertarian administration I don't think
we're going to achieve that unless we're
picking up the pieces you know and I
don't want that to happen I'd like to
avoid the chaos and that's my goal but
if there's if there's an economic
calamity and they look to the
libertarians for solutions then I think
it's conceivable but that be more like
being in a profit than somebody running
for president you know and and I just
don't know how this happened will happen
but I do believe though if we continue
to do what we're doing continue to spend
run up the deficit print to money I
think we are going to have the crisis
but right now I'm terrified to think
that the people in Washington aren't
going to look to us for the answers
they're going to enforce these emergency
powers and FEMA will be in control not
the American people can you did your
committee look into the matter of the
debt which foreign countries owed to the
so-called US banks yes that's been done
going is certainly 1982 was a key year
because there was a big bailout of
Mexico and Argentina and Brazil in order
to patch it together and they did
everything illegal just like it was
illegally done even admitted by Dawn
Reagan who was Secretary of Treasury -
it was the illegal on how they bailed
out continental Illinois and they do
whatever is necessary to keep the
structure together the system together
if big banks gobble up little banks but
nothing in disintegrates it's not like
what was happening in the 1920's 1930's
and they'll do whatever is necessary so
that's what happened back in 1982 they
work internationally - the Federal
Reserve the Tri
the World Bank Bank of International
Settlements which is the depositor for
all the central bank's so you have the
Federal Reserve Bank's depositing in the
Federal Reserve System but the central
banks of the United States and all the
other countries used the Bank of
International Settlements in Switzerland
to be the internationals bankers Bank
and they all got involved to keep the
structure together and they did they
restored order that was back when gold
went quickly from 300 dollars up to 500
dollars within a six-month period but
then they saw that the market is out up
it looks like our gonna hold it together
for a while longer and they certainly
have at the expense of the American
taxpayer and at the expense of the
dollar
of course since then the dollars value
has gone down 40 50 percent in value of
other currency prices continue to rise
but eventually my argument is that the
marketplace will overwhelm even those
men of great power and there will be a
panic that the bankers won't be able to
maintain and then they will want to
maintain their power but not by not by
fine-tuning the economy but then by the
intimidation of political force I
noticed very little talked about thing
that this is from the alternative press
where the head of the Fed Paul Volcker
got a little bill or a little sentence
on a writer on a bill passed through
Congress that if necessary the foreign
debt that these third-world countries to
the US banks would be monitor eyes would
use just way of saying that the US
taxpayers would pay for it yes this was
part of that monetary Control Act and
that means that if the Fed can hold any
asset they can hold a foreign bond they
literally another law today can buy a
mexican bond that's worthless put it in
the federal reserve and then what
monetized means is that it can be
collateral for issuing credit issuing
Federal Reserve notes and that will be
considered an asset probably at face
value they're not going too deep I mean
the bond isn't gonna be worth anything
obviously but they can monetize that
that is mean they will take it as an
asset create new money and distribute
that the money
so that isn't a direct bailout by
attacks it's probably it's an indirect
because what we do is we buy the Mexican
bond and then put the bond in the
Federal Reserve but actually it works
twice because let's say the Mexican bond
there's a billion dollars worth of
Mexican bonds down there so the Fed says
well we'll buy them you need some hard
cash we'll buy your bond from you and we
give them the money and they take that
out of out of the system and they send
it to them but then when they take it's
an asset it becomes an asset to the
Federal Reserve and I say AHA we have
something we can back up our currency
with so they take this worthless
instrument that they paid for with fiat
money and then they put it in their
assets and then they create use that to
create more money so they really
monetize it twice so to speak how
closely tied is the Federal Reserve
System and the US banking system with
the European banking system to
Rothschild so the international bankers
are buddies you know and they're they're
closer together and they deal with
policy outside most of the legislative
institutions the central bankers are
more powerful than say the Congress is
of the different countries they have
much more power and therefore through
the Bank of International Settlement and
the IMF and the World Bank they have
total control of this and they have
meetings where even the secretary of the
Treasury doesn't attend it's strictly
the bankers the photo Reserve and the
Bundestag and all the other banks of the
world they get together and they make
these plans and that's why they come up
with the bailout systems you know if
there's a banking crisis someplace but
they they will do whatever they think is
necessary by the creation of new credit
right now they have made the agreement
that they will create more the Special
Drawing rights which is nothing more
than credit instruments in the IMF they
create them out of thin air they have a
monetary value in all based in all
currencies and they can give those to
whoever needs them and they've just
agreed to create 40 billion dollars
worth of new Special Drawing rights out
of thin air